alors si par malheur vous avez raté le
fameux bac il vous est toujours possible
de redoubler et puis il ya tout de même
une vie tout court et une vie
professionnelle sans le bac
contrairement à ce que certains pensent
toute une série de bts sont à votre
disposition encore écoles privées
spécialisées avec une réelle formation à
terme formulaire et michel levasseur
sont allés aux renseignements peau est
le premier conseil c'est évidemment de
dire de repasser son bac parce que
c'était quand même primordial d'avoir
son bac pour cheville filières
d'enseignement supérieur la deuxième
chose c'est d'aller travailler
et puis reprendre ses études après parce
qu'on peut rentrer à l'université avec
un dea diplôme d'accès aux études
universitaires qui permet de reprendre 1
2 puis une licence
après 2 ans d'expérience professionnelle
et puis si on veut contre vence
démarrait sur une formation
d'enseignement supérieur on peut aller
dans les formations ouvertes à des
personnes qui ont le niveau bac
des bts parfois des iut et des filières
le puy spécialisées dans le domaine
artistique ou dans le domaine du
commerce
et bien sûr il reste enfin la
qualification ou l'apprentissage qui
sont également ouvertes et formations
qui sont également ouvert aux titulaires
ou non titulaires du bac c'est vrai que
l'apprentissage ça par contre toutes les
qualités
ça permet d'être rémunéré pendant ses
études le bénéficier d'un diplôme
reconnu par l'état est bien sûr
éventuellement d'avoir un métier
le cas échéant donc c'est vrai que ça
tous les avantages et ça permet surtout
de se s'engager dans des filières de
pointe comme l'informatique l'avant
l'hôtellerie la restauration et même des
secteurs encore plus technique